so we're celebrating all the fields
February has this Valentine's Day so you
have anybody special I do my boyfriend
Anthony the love of my hide
yes I don't know what we're gonna do or
probably just gonna like stay at home
and just eat like we do best date ever
y'all heard well that's us look at him
in that hat okay yeah oh look at this
one that's my puppy Emmy Emmy is
adorable I love your man but I love yeah
yeah yeah her Emmys a girl yeah yes yes
yes butyl she we just celebrated her
one-year one years old and when you're
being with us because we got our like
five weeks and she knows she knows that
it's that it's her one year because we
woke up and I'm a little sick so Anthony
went and took her out on her morning
walk and she pooped in the shape of a
heart
now I would like to say that I have a
picture of the said that's impressive
and I could shut it get challenged yeah
I just want I want to know if you feel
like mm not the vibe please look away
but yeah I the phone you have a photos
of heart poop of the boy if you wanna
look at our Pacino I want to look at the
heart poop
[Applause]
that's actually very impressive
have you thought I'd say you guys I mean
the only thing better is if she just
stopped behind and was like yeah like
after I will not stop talking until you
subscribe to my youtube channel that's
right and I could talk a lot seriously
not gonna stop yep still here not going
anywhere I see you don't walk away from
this